this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
everybody i hope you're having a
terrific week i've read some
interesting and very fun books uh this
past month and
whatever amount of time let's cut the
chit chat and get straight into it all
right the first book i read this year
was a bit of a surprise to me actually i
i read this because nadia read this a
while ago and she really liked it and i
wanted to see and it was very popular at
the time i wanted to see what the fuss
was about the book is the silent patient
by
alex mikulides i don't know how to
pronounce that i think it's greek i have
some thoughts on this uh it was a fast
read the chapters are really short which
i like light on description
straight to the point look the reason
you read this book is for the twist
there's
a huge twist on the back of the books
like oh these you you're a thriller fan
you have no idea what's coming for you
you'll never see it coming and no i
didn't see it coming but felt a little
cheated felt like a bit of a trick but i
don't want to get into it i did really
enjoy the book actually me and nadia
recorded a chat about the book an
in-depth conversation about it which uh
will be appearing on a new channel very
soon there's gonna be an official
announcement about this later and stuff
but second channel incoming look for
that so i'm not gonna talk any more
about the silent patient the next book i
read is um was it was just a blind buy
at this bookstore uh i like to go to i
think it's called skylight books i've
never read any patricia high smith book
she's the author of the ripley novels
talented mr ripley ripley's game ripley
underground all those books she wrote
carol or the price of salt anyways i had
never read any of her work and this was
a book that they had there not her most
famous book i wish i had been a little
less impulsive honestly this was not the
book for me it's called those who walk
away and the reason i picked it out i
think is because it's set in venice i
like reading books in places that are
set where i've visited you have a better
mental picture of what's going on it's
like you're getting to revisit the trip
a little bit and the premise of the book
was so interesting it's like a cat and
mouse chase two guys trying to kill each
other but it's the father-in-law and the
son-in-law the reason i don't recommend
it is because it doesn't go much beyond
the premise and i think that may have
been the point that she was trying to to
make
look the writing was beautiful i loved
following the characters the reason i
stuck with it for so long was because
i
felt like there was there was more i
liked the characters i liked the setup i
liked the general tone it was just a
dark kind of brooding tone
but what didn't work for me was that
it was almost like an anti-thriller it
almost becomes comical
and i i don't think i don't know if it
was intentional or not boring so boring
and frustrating the characters were not
acting like characters they were
almost too too realistic in that they
did nothing you have a character who is
comically over the top like i'm going to
kill you i'm going to kill you and then
you have the the other character who was
ineffective not gonna do anything just
oh you're gonna try to kill me again oh
no i guess i should probably avoid you
this father-in-law is targeting the
son-in-law repeatedly to
kill him pushes him off a boat into the
ocean freezing water to die
um and this guy just disappeared it's
called those who walk away you know he
just disappears in venice makes it seem
like he died and it's kind of playing
these mind games with the father-in-law
because you think he's gonna have enough
he's been shot he's been thrown into the
water later he gets hit almost hit over
the head with like a crowbar or a piece
of pipe you think this guy is gonna it's
there's gonna be
enough he's just gonna be like no more
i'm coming after you it doesn't happen
there's no catharsis it's just like
well
i guess he'll never understand me kind
of regret that this was the first high
smith book i read i don't regret reading
it i did get something from it now after
reading those who walked away not very
bloody not very it's just very much in
the head i needed something to get me
excited who else better than uh jean
patrick manchette french crime writer
wrote in the 70s the 80s i've talked
about him a bunch the new york review of
books they put out a number of his books
and a very new translation they just put
out is called the i don't even know how
to pronounce it the uh n gustro affair
it's new so uh it's new but it's old the
thing was his first it was his breakout
book actually it's a bizarre book it's
really bizarre it's quick it feels like
a movie the writing is just like
blunt into the point and like
you're not going to read this kind of
writing
now from anyone classic noir kind of
like uh setup of the guy's recording the
story of his life on a tape player right
before he dies
you know it's like double indemnity but
this is based on an actual political
event that happened the assassination of
a i forget who it was but of a
uh revolutionary leftist revolutionary
uh his assassination and the scandal
that surrounded that this book is
written from the point of view of a
really nasty
sicko well he's just a criminal he's
just like a delinquent kid he just like
gets into trouble he doesn't have like a
bad upbringing he's just like a bad
person and he gets involved in fascist
groups and like the political organizing
and college and stuff and he just likes
he joins the fascists not because
he
believes in anything he doesn't believe
in anything he just likes beating up the
anarchists and the communists it's very
sex-focused like this guy all he thinks
about is like sex he ends up becoming
the bodyguard of this revolutionary he's
tricked into helping kill this
revolutionary because he wants to make a
movie so it's why i honestly just i
don't really know what to think about it
it's not it doesn't feel very focused
it's kind of all over
the place those manchet books i could
just dive into them and just be immersed
uh kind of like when i uh
dive into skillshare you like what i did
there skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creators explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity with
skillshare i've been using skillshare
obviously and finding some really
interesting classes i've been very much
into writing and writing routines and
craft and stuff like that i like
learning about writers
i found a really
great course actually that's all about
writing routines it's called the
writer's toolkit six steps to a
successful writing habit by simon van
boy it's about setting a good routine
that works for you finding very
practical and that's what i like about
writing advice that's what i look for
and there's all sorts of great writing
courses there's like science fiction
fantasy courses all that sort of stuff
on skillshare and what i like about it
is that you can take it in bite-sized
chunks or you can watch the whole thing
over you know you can just just binge it
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused skillshare now offers
classes in spanish french portuguese and
german the first thousand people to
click on the link in the description get
skillshare for free for one month yeah
so check it out the next book i read is
called hitman um
just hitman by this writer lawrence
block i don't know how i stumbled into
lawrence block's writing i think it was
through donald wesley anyways he
collaborated a few times with lawrence
block and i just kind of heard lawrence
block discussed i saw some of his
interviews with craig ferguson it's
called hitman and i didn't realize that
it's actually a collection of short
stories they kind of tie in together and
create a longer narrative but it's very
episodic put together they make a nice
little novel hey i don't have that much
time to read but i can get through one
of these stories and each chapter is
like 10 chapters so like 10 different
stories really compelling
i
love these stories they're so well
written it's so clear to the point crisp
cutting out all the fat lean lean lean i
love it i love this kind of writing
dialogue is
smart and
it's funny
but dark
it reminds me a lot of barry
one of my favorite tv shows interesting
moral situations it becomes like
a thing like there's there's one story
where there are two guys hire him to
kill each other and they don't know it
so he's he's on an assignment and he's
tasked with he basically has to decide
which one to kill one client or the
other and he's trying to figure out you
know what would be fair so he starts
talking to the friends and family of
these guys who we may kill to decide
okay i'll just kill the worst guy well
neither of them are really worse so he's
thinking well he loves his dog this this
guy loves his dog the hitman
and he his name is keller so he starts
asking them well how do they feel about
dogs so he's trying to figure out like
okay if one likes dogs then i'll kill
the other guy who doesn't like dogs but
he can't decide and um ends up just
killing them both i'm definitely going
to be reading more lawrence block very
soon and finally speaking of writing
advice writing routines um i read
possibly the greatest book of writing
advice ever um
and it's a lawrence block
and it's just called writing the novel
and it takes just piece by piece every
element you know characters uh story
structure pace uh chapter length uh
revisions everything very practical
that's what i love in a writing book i
don't like reading
books about writing that are like just
divine inspiration that's why i love
brandon sanderson's lecture so much is
because it's just very much like if you
want to know how to write a good
character
this is how you know there are things
you can know there are technic
techniques you know it's a craft
lawrence block has some amazing amazing
um advice you know one of one of my
favorite things in there is about uh you
start a story and you start from the
beginning but he says you know one of
the best things to do is just in one of
his editors i guess at some point in his
career said switch the second to the
first chapter
you know you can change the transitions
a little bit but you just need to get
the character you just need to get
readers engaged immediately it's just
great yeah i love it i love it i love it
any of his writing books i'm sure
they're all great and cover a lot of the
same stuff long story short that's what
i've been reading lately i hope you're
having a good year so far don't stress
about your reading goals just read
whatever
don't don't read a book that's that you
don't want to anyways thanks for
watching everybody have a good one